installment in our series is judy
shelton a research fellow at the hoover
institution at stanford university
she joined us for an hour-long
discussion of her book the coming soviet
crash
gorbachev's desperate pursuit of credit
in western financial markets
[Music]
dr judy shelton author of the coming
soviet crash
what's your book all about
the book has two main parts to it the
first part describes the condition of
the soviet economy their financial
situation
the second part is aimed at explaining
how the soviets are able to get
financial capital from the west
my my goal was to explain first
why the soviets need the money
and secondly how they're able to get it
because i think you need to go through
that part of the problem before you can
begin to address the issue of whether or
not the west and particularly the us
should be party to the financing of the
soviet economy
should they be
i think not
i think it's um
it's a travesty
for people in this country
who have incurred the burden certainly
as taxpayers of supporting a huge
defense
expenditure
to then turn around and work against
themselves
in financing the soviet economy when
soviet military capabilities are
directly linked to soviet economic
strength
when did you first say to yourself i
wanna i feel strong enough about this
issue you want to write a book about it
well
i wasn't really inspired so much by the
policy question that we're now talking
about at the beginning is by the
importance of getting good numbers just
as
an exercise and doing an academic study
of how much the soviets actually owed to
the west
in may of 1984 while i was looking at
general levels of
global indebtedness
i learned that
soviet debt had been systematically
underestimated in the west
and people generally felt it was about
half
what we suddenly learned it truly was
and that struck me as
as odd not just in terms of shouldn't we
have better monitoring abilities but but
this is a soviet union
and it would seem to me that our
financial relationship with the soviets
deserved more scrutiny
than with other countries and yet the
numbers were so bad
what was the source of the numbers
well the organization for economic
cooperation and development out of paris
tracks government credits to different
countries
and the bank for international
settlements in basel looks at commercial
credits
before the before may 84 the bis this
latter group
gave out statistics on commercial debt
but they joined forces with the oecd at
that time
and that's when it was suddenly made
apparent that
the soviet union
has
was indebted to western governments
almost as much as it was indebted to
commercial banks
no one had had thought that an
industrial power like the soviet union
would be getting these official credits
from western governments usually those
are reserved for
developing countries or backward
countries who can't get commercial
financing it's kind of a favor from
western governments to give them a shot
at at participating in trade
and so um the wall street journal at
that time ran an article pointing out
that
this is news and i investigated uh the
oecd reports the bis
i went to paris i went to basil and met
with the people who put together the
statistics
and said what are you now counting
are there other figures that we're not
including
so my my original emphasis was
on the numbers and a concern over what i
considered lacks monitoring procedures
where were you at the time that you
first started your research
i was at the hoover institution
i was working as research assistant to
senior fellow martin anderson
he had been reagan's chief domestic
economic policy advisor
and he was still
active in the president's
economic advisory board and one of the
projects that he had me looking at
was to analyze the numbers on
the
indebtedness level for a number of
countries so it was in doing that
project for him
that i noted that the soviet union was
one of those heavily indebted countries
your background is in education and
finance and business administration how
much time where were you between the
time that you were
a phd
candidate at the university of utah and
an mba
degree at university of utah on a bs
portland state university how did you
get to stanford and the hoover institute
well when i was going into my final year
on my doctorate at the university of
utah
at about that time my husband was a
banker in a
a rather large bank in salt lake city
he was beginning to think that
regulations in the financial industry
were such that
banking decisions that an individual
manager might make could be squelched in
an instant by a new law coming out of
washington
he was upset with rules that
no longer made it a level playing field
for people in the financial industry
so we decided that we would each take
about a year
to get out of our our respective
situations and at that time we'd been
married about four years
and my situation was to complete my
degree to
to write a good dissertation
and
his was to
to
finish one career and and maybe have
some free time and in the future we
decide what we would want to do
and as it turns out my my dissertation
was composed of two research projects
and the first one
won an award
for the best doctoral paper and was
published in the journal financial and
quantitative analysis subject
really one of those those weird
intellectual
exercises that people in the academic
community involve themselves with it was
called an option pricing theory
to
banking and
and it really it tried to describe
a risk-free investment which is what a
bank deposit is supposed to be
in terms of a structure of options as
some combination of a put option and a
call option which on paper if combined
would equate a riskless investment with
some kind of striking price which i
thought was the amount at which you
would throw money so it was one of those
you did lots of little diagrams and
numbers and it was
clever i'm not sure it had great
application in the real world was the
other dissertation the other one was on
it was called
equal access and miller's equilibrium
and it was an attempt to refute what
someone who's sort of a giant in
financial theory had said
about
what would happen if individuals and
corporations were taxed at different
rates who would end up issuing all of
the debt in the world and the idea was
if if corporations had a 70 tax bracket
and they could shield that much income
uh they would be the ones to issue all
the debt and if individuals were in a 50
tax bracket they would all always issue
debt through corporations so it actually
wasn't a refutation so much as well if
what he's saying is so
then to take it to its logical
conclusion and this is a long way from
the soviet union
my my interest
has been in financial theory and
international banking and economics and
still for me
international monetary reform
is is the greater
interest and and what i will return to
the soviet union
because i'm interested in revenues and
expenditures and all financial issues
when i when i started focusing on how
much they were borrowing
and then why did they need the money and
that got me into looking at their
internal budget statement
which was then
from my accounting perspective which is
different than the typical
sovietologist who's an economist
i got interested in the numbers on the
soviet situation but in a sense this is
a specific
even an aberration from what i consider
my first love which is financial theory
and application in international banking
and economics
martin anderson was a political type
i think he's both in fact i think he's a
perfect combination of
an intellectual from the academic
community but a pragmatist who has seen
how
policy can
stem from ideas but ultimately affect
people's everyday life is this book the
coming soviet crash
those are just joining us we're talking
with dr judy shelton and we will be for
the next 50 minutes or so is this book
political will have a political overtone
to it
or political fallout may be the best
question yeah i i think it definitely is
having that already
and that's interesting to me because
my focus from the beginning was to
produce an analytical study
but what came out of that
in in going through the statistics on
the soviet budget
and figuring out why they are now under
gorbachev
making such
radical uh
taking these initiatives in western
financial markets that on a scale that's
never been
exercised before by the soviet union and
in an array of options that they've
never
had the opportunity to even pursue
before making the connection between
their situation and how they're
attempting to rectify it
that analysis then gave way to
or i should say the policy
recommendations
that that i draw in the book
fell out of the analysis
the original
focus was an analytical approach
but secondly it has strong political
overtones
what do you think of the soviet union
i think that
it's an idea that went wrong
economically i
think it's doomed
um
and i i don't say that with glee
i've only been to the soviet union on
one occasion for a couple of weeks
i liked it very much it's treated very
nicely
in some ways i'm
i'm probably a closet to slavophile i
like the russian language i work at it
every day
i like
russian literature
so
one problem with the book or at least
for me is i've had
the sense of people thinking that i
i want to see the soviet union collapse
i
don't like the soviet government i don't
like
the soviet government's emphasis on
military strength as its claim to
superpower status
i think it's misplaced it bothers me
that the soviet government
puts
first priority on economic resources on
talent on r d investment
that all goes to the military then comes
fixed capital investment for the
infrastructure of the countries for
factories for dams and in a
sad third place
comes expenditures on behalf of the
people
and i think that
what i would like to see i guess
dissipate
and collapse
is a government that
draws its power from this these military
capabilities from the potential to rig
violence on the rest of the world i
don't think that's a legitimate claim to
power
i would certainly rather see
those resources
transferred from the military sector in
the soviet economy to the consumption
sector let me ask you this is
way off the of the subject of your book
per se but it might help at least me
understand how this money thing works
take pepsico
you can i guess you can buy pepsico in
the soviet union yes
how does that work how does the pepsi
cola company of the united states
let's let's take it through from the the
uh
the consumer in the soviet union who
walks up somewhere and says give me a
pepsi and here's a ruble and i have no
what's a ruble uh translated to an
american dollar any way to do that yeah
well there's two ways to do it and one
is the official soviet government's rate
of exchange and that says that
one ruble is worth a dollar 62. so
they're saying a rule is worth 60
percent more one ruble 60 more than one
dollar
the other way to to relate those two
currencies is to walk on the street in
moscow and stop in front of the
bookstore and wait to be approached
at which point you'll be offered six to
eight times the official rate if you're
willing to engage in this dangerous
black market activity of trading in
dollars for rubles okay but let's go to
the pepsi i woke up and i i'm a soviet
citizen and i put a ruble down for one
pepsi
trace that ruble back to where to the
pepsi cola headquarters where they
eventually have something
in exchange for their goods
well
i don't know pepsi's exact arrangement
but there's two ways that that american
companies or any western company can do
it can extract some kind of money some
kind of compensation from the soviet
union and one way would be
you use the rubles that you earn from
operations in the soviet union to buy
goods inventory materials to pay soviet
workers but then you run
another operation and the other
operation only takes hard currency for
instance pizza hut
has a a
setup to do that where one restaurant
serves soviet people and they can pay in
rubles and then the money that's taken
in that way is used to buy tomatoes and
cheese and resources and then it's in
the hard currency one where it's not for
soviet citizens it's for tourists or
it's for privileged soviet people who
have dollars or maybe people who've
gotten them um
illegally but at any point they only
take hard currency
and then it's a profits from the second
operation that could be repatriated back
home
now another way to do it and as i
understand it pepsi is is working on the
second way
and does some business on the basis of
barter
where they use the rubles to
buy stalichnia and they have rights to
sell stalichnia vodka in the united
states
is it worth worth it for an american
company to go over there and do business
i don't see how even from a bottom line
dollars and cents
not for the soviet consumer i mean
there's this much touted
great um
market of soviet people who are dying
for western produced goods well they
absolutely are no question if you came
over and put a thousand pair of jeans on
the shelves i guarantee they'd be gone
in half an hour and you could charge
virtually whatever you want because
aruba is so inflated that the people
have have tons of currency piled up it's
sitting in savings accounts it's it's
virtually meaningless to them so they'll
just pay it it's the difficult thing for
most soviet citizens is translating the
money into consumer goods it's not
getting the money many have been
overpaid for years
so in that sense an american will find
he can sell his stuff then what does he
do with all of these rubles then he's
left to wrangle with the soviet
government
as to what's going to be the rate at
which i turn in all of this ruble money
which is going to look like monopoly
money to him
make it meaningful i don't want to spend
it in the soviet union chances are
an american is not going to find much
that intrigues him in the way of
manufactured goods that he wants to then
turn around and buy
soviet-produced goods
so um what's the difference between the
soviet ruble and the way
american business would interact and the
british pound for instance
well it's the same thing i mean the uh
the soviet ruble is an inconvertable
currency against all western currencies
so everyone's in the same boat the
inflation is internal i'm sorry what's
the difference between the way we relate
to great britain and the way we relate
to the soviet union when you say
inconvertible who decides it's
inconverted well
since um 73 we've been on a floating
exchange system so our currency is
valued daily in the market on the basis
of
let's say relative to the british pound
sterling as to
what the world demand is for dollars
versus pound sterling so those are
that's constantly being judged by the
market by the laws of demand and supply
that is the black market rate i mean for
us the black market rate is a legitimate
rate the soviet union the legitimate
rate is illegal the legitimate rate
would be what you're offered on the
street who decides that i know these are
terribly simple questions but for
somebody has no background in it how do
you do how do you explain
the way this thing what would how could
you change
so you'd have a convertible rate with
rubles who makes that decision well the
soviet government could agree to
let its ruble be convertible it could
suddenly say in world markets whatever
people are willing to pay for it that's
i mean make it subject to the same rules
of supply and demand that the other
currencies now follow why don't they
well it would be
impossible for
the soviet government to reconcile
this world valuation of its currency
with
the artificial rate that it has set
internally because what we're talking
about now is is
how do you deal with the difference in
valuation between the black market rate
and what the government continues to
stipulate that the official value is
if you
i assume you're a
capitalist very much so okay let's say
that you wanted to
help the soviet union and they called
you up and said dr shelton come over
here and tell us how we can become like
the united states is it possible
i don't think it's possible for them to
become like the united states if we're
talking about personal freedom
which in our country goes right along
with economic freedom and they're trying
to impose
in a sense capitalism from the top down
and what gorbachev is doing is borrowing
some aspects of capitalism
unfortunately the harshest aspects of
capitalism which are
bankruptcy the possibility of failing
and
unemployment he's using
that part of capitalism just as an
emergency measure
now
if i was going to advise the soviet
government from a financial point of
view what they could do to take part in
the international international
financial system monetary system
i would urge them to
put their money where their mouth is so
to speak and and come up with a gold
back ruble
i think that the soviet union's only
claim to credibility
with western
financial
types
is to provide collateral behind a
currency in fact i think it would be a
rather
um
brilliant coup on their part
to come out with the currency that they
agree to redeem and goal because they
have mythical holdings not not mythical
in the sense that they don't exist
but
bankers eyes just get
round when they think of soviet gold
reserves so there is this
implicit assumption on our part that
they do have something valuable and
clearly i think they're the world's
second largest producer they do have
gold
so if i were them
i would come out first
with a
bond that had gold warrants
maybe three years out that way they
could provide an instrument that you
cannot duplicate in the market you can't
get futures on goal that far out i think
they would get a fantastic premium not
just because of the novelty of a
goldback bond although other governments
have done it successfully
but also because uh the soviet union
there's the novelty of them being
relatively new borrowers in the euro
bond market so i think they'd get a
double premium
i don't think they'd ever have to redeem
the goal as long as nothing radical
change with the soviet union in a
negative way politically so there is at
risk of course it'd be in our interest
to give them incentive not to let
anything radical happen
involving any kind of violent
suppression of say republic movements
i also think that
if the soviets were to do this they'd be
somewhat exposed
when the time came to redeem the bond if
the price of gold had gone up because
then this warrant would require them to
furnish gold at a cheaper price than it
was available in world markets
but
with their with the soviet ability to
influence the world price of gold i even
think they could protect themselves on
the downside
by reducing the price just about the
time they have to redeem
i don't know why i'd want to give all
this great advice to the soviets but i
think that it's healthier for us
to
get out in front of gorbachev what i
think he's starting to do now is set the
terms of trade
and he's doing rather well at
negotiating
uh a welfare payment mentality in the
west where i think we're willing to
make a one-way transfer
of um
physical and financial capital
why are we willing to do that and who's
going i hope we're not but certainly
certainly our allies west germany
england
france and italy have been making
tremendous reserves of cash available to
the soviets why do they want to do that
they are
victims i think of this entrenched
political
quid pro quo that says
if the soviets make progress on arms
control
on human rights
on
regional conflicts
we will bail them out with economic and
financial favors
so i think that
these west european allies in japan are
now saying well the soviets are
performing
we now have to come through on our part
of the deal
let's pay them off i mean britain's
just concluded over a billion dollar
trade negotiation um
they've agreed to
at the expense of the british government
trained soviet managers at the london
business school
so clearly the uh the governments are
are intermingling with what should be
private commercial transactions and
they're pushing this agenda of providing
financial assistance to the soviet union
do american government leaders feel
greatly different about this in your
opinion from what you've seen than the
west germans and the great
and the british and the japanese
i think they feel somewhat different but
if and if they do why
the big reason is because the united
states bears the brunt of the defense
burden of the west
so to
to u.s citizens and to our leaders
it appears as if
at the same time we are
protecting europe through our nato
commitment they're undercutting us
by giving this economic succor to the
soviet union which certainly enhances uh
the total amount of resources available
to the soviet union
and tapping into what i said earlier
about the military sector always having
a priority claim on resources
i think in the united states we feel
that
the europeans are contributing
to
soviet military potential and and we
have to then match that concurrently
in defense costs to match any new
escalation of soviet military
capabilities
so um
i think it's very um
disconcerting to the united states to
see its allies moving ahead so strongly
when did you go to the soviet union
i was there in september 1987.
and
had you finished your book yet
um
i'd finished the
original draft and
and then i i did subsequent work
updating statistics were there on
business or on on pleasure
really pleasure just wanted to see it as
i say i am
i have no problem with um
with the russian people or the russian
heritage
i have
real differences with the soviet
government and its priorities but i
enjoyed my visit
did you change your mind about anything
from what you thought the place was
going to be like
during the time that you wrote the book
and
when you got there
things were
worse
than i expected
my study was based on numbers
and looking at
government figures and statistics
when you see
economic problems on paper it doesn't
hit you as hard as as when you go out
and see
decrepit buildings and
lousy roads
um most telling for my husband and i was
we had we had wonderful guides in both
moscow and leningrad
and the young lady who
who
took care of us in moscow she
accompanied us to dinner and at the end
of the meal
sitting on the table
was a little stand with some
bad peaches i mean visibly
rotting
with
holes on them peaches
and we'd had a sumptuous meal and our
guide
wasn't interested didn't have any
but she looked around at the end of the
meal
taken away the last of the plates
and she whispered she says are you going
to eat that fruit and
she said no no we're not
she said would you mind if
if i had some and she said no of course
help yourself and she looked around and
she opened her big bag
and she dumped it
into her bag
and the next morning told us that her
son thanked us her mother thanked us her
father thanked us and it was the first
fruit they'd had that year
and um the contrast between the the way
we were treated actually i think we had
luxury accommodations and great meals
contrary to what a lot of people have
told me their experience has been
and this very telling example from this
young lady
who had a pretty good job
made me realize in addition to what i
was observing
on the streets for myself the lines and
the stores
the general rundown condition of
virtually everything
had a stronger impact than the numbers
had ever had
can you explain it
in addition to what you've said here in
your book about the
difference in the economic
situation what it is about our
country and the way we run our
economy and the way the soviets run
theirs
that
creates a different mentality in the in
the on the part of the people what are
the different elements of it that
uh
i don't know that i'm being very
articulate but create more consumer
goods and better goods and
uh
the
contrast the differences what what is it
well there's there's a long answer and a
short answer and the long one gets into
the structure of the government and who
owns the means of production
uh the short answer i think is
the lack of competition
when you have central planning
dictating the production of goods which
then causes managers to fulfill a
quota
rather than have any real interest in
what consumers might prefer to have
you lose innovation
in production and manufacturing there's
no point in coming up with something
bigger or better because um there's no
incentive to do so why take the risk go
back to that those peaches
would you expect in most american
situations those peaches would be good
if it were a private restaurant
that um
got its business on the basis of word of
mouth
and people here i think have pretty
tough standards on
what they expect in restaurants i think
the difference is there if you get bad
beaches
who do you complain to the restaurants
commissioned by
by a central authority
and clients complaining there's very
little
in in determining the the future of the
viability of that restaurant in the eyes
of the central planet is there anything
about the soviet society that you saw in
consumer goods that were equal to what
we have here in your opinion
caviar
the caviar the cars now the cars were
running the hotel
um
the one in moscow we stayed at um
was adequate
the one in leningrad was excellent it
was built by the finns
so i i can't complain but i think my
experience was unique again other
american visitors are shocked when i
tell them that that i actually had
rather nice accommodations what about
their airplanes
my flu pan am
i don't know i didn't take soviet
airplanes
i did take the soviet train but again it
was a
rather romantic experience it was
pleasant it was all right i mean in some
ways the soviets can perform
think think of that industry trains
something like that lends itself to
central planning i suppose
i mean we really have amtrak
our train system is not an area that is
characterized by a lot of competition so
i think they can do all right i mean
look at their space program look at
their military abilities um there are
some areas that the soviet government
has pinpointed and when you put all that
power and resources behind a few
selected projects
they're going to come out all right
the problem is
the variation in the system to to be
able i mean literally
to send people into outer space and not
be able to produce acceptable shoes for
children
the contrast is just terrific and i
think it's the distortions the um
the the pockets of of
innovation and state-of-the-art
technology which in the soviet union
tend to occur in the military sector
again
versus in the consumption sector where
they're still using an abacus
and making you line up three times to
purchase
a book
or anything
the soviet system where it relates to
consumers is so backward
that that i think is is the sin of the
soviet government neglecting
soviet citizens in favor
of
becoming a superpower thug
could you could you sense from visiting
there for the short time that the people
there are happy unhappy how would you
compare them with the general mood of
americans
you know that's a um
that's a question
that i think reflects human nature i'm
i'm not sure that a
highly
consumerist society
means
greater personal happiness for an
individual
the people i met
happy enough i think they had that that
russian characteristic of being resigned
i think they're much more passive than
americans we're so demanding if
something's not up to snuff
we call the manager
in the soviet union they shrug it off
and if they get lucky they're able to
buy this or that it's good fortune
but um you you wouldn't begin to see
irritation
of uh like you would in the united
states you said earlier that a day
didn't go by that you don't fool around
with russian in some way how do you why
um
i've always liked the literature tolstoy
and dostoevsky
and pushkin and goggle and
what i'm trying to do now is
um i'm trying to memorize
a day in the life of ivan de nisovich by
soldier nitzen
so i i have tapes
of solzhenitsyn reciting his work
and then i have a russian russian or
english in russian
and then i have the work in russian and
i have it in english and i have about
four
english russian dictionaries and
every morning
for an hour
i start reciting what i've memorized so
far
and adding on to it and working my way
through the book why
it's
it's a great pleasure i
i think the way you you get a feel for
language unfortunately is through this
exercise of memorization
so i need to hear it
and read it
and think about it so it has meaning to
me personally to really embrace it
and it's just nice it's really
interesting to see the different
perspectives on life
that can show up in one language versus
another the way something's expressed
in english
and then you read the same paragraph in
the original russian
the nuance might be slightly different
and
it's it's just a pleasurable
exercise
to feel like you're capturing that did
you get interested in
russian literature and
language as a result of your book or is
this something you've always had um i've
been interested long before i was
focusing on the
the more
economic financial numbers problems of
the soviet union this is a this is just
a parallel interest and uh
a couple of years ago
at our house
out in middleburg
my husband
in virginia right
um he indulged me by
we contracted with a gentleman who had
set up a satellite system
for colombia to listen in on soviet
television we set up
the same operation at our house
and it involves a big dish
and a little computer
and since the soviet
satellite is not
geostationary and i am not i don't know
anything about these things except what
was explained to me but the soviet
satellite keeps moving so the trick to
latch onto it is to get a system that
can follow it and track it
so our our dish now wired to this
computer
does a little search about every eight
minutes
figures out which is the strongest
direction the strongest signal and locks
onto that and follows out for a little
while
in the meantime feeds through
and in my office set up in the house i
can watch
color soviet television from about uh
4 30 in the afternoon to about 7 30 in
the morning
that comes out of light of a stock
and then i get live soviet radio
straight out of moscow all day long so
i it's a pleasure for me to hear the
language i enjoy that i don't pretend to
understand all of it but
i can get some of it and every once in a
while there's something interesting that
comes on the news
what have you learned by being able to
peek in on their television system
well
um
some of the things that that have
already been noted by others and that is
that remia has a much
more much more use of graphics and
marketing and is a much more lively show
than it used to be when now they still
lapse into
statistics on grain production and this
republic fulfilled its quota on on
grapes and
it gets pretty boring in some ways it's
the old soviet style of giving the news
which means look comrades your your
fellow comrades are just doing a swell
job in the ukraine
it's a little more
has a little more flair
one thing i still resent on the soviet
television on the news is
whatever was the worst story
that week in the united states maybe
something awful a ku klux klan
demonstration
or a someone goes crazy and and shoots
four people
boy that's
first thing on the soviet news in the
united states this week bam
and they show the the worst side of us
and i think we're we're so much more
forthcoming about showing positive
things and casting a human light on the
soviets
than they are toward us
if you've just joined us we're talking
about this book which is published by
free press and it's called the coming
soviet crash and our guest is dr judy
shelton who is a
research fellow with the hoover
institution
at stanford university
and this book was it's got a copyright
of 1989. when did you finish it
i finished it
about
february
of 88
and i did some updating of statistics
the latest numbers that were available
to me
maybe as late as may
and um bringing some tables
what's the publisher free press
uh it's a division of mcmillan in new
york
and is this meant to be a consumer
book i think it's a hybrid macmillan is
more of a textbook publisher
uh the free press
the publisher is irwin glickes who has a
lot of experience with other major
publishers who aim their books at
people who walk into bookstores off the
street so this is his special
project to produce books that
have somewhat of a scholarly approach
that are analytical but the policy
implications are important to members of
the public
and so it's it's a trade book in the
sense that i think someone who has an
interest in the soviet economic
situation
who's aware of
policy implications in our relations
toward them might pick it up and and get
a better understanding
anybody react negatively to your book
yes
yes
it was
it received i would have to say and
maybe i'm
i'm
giving the benefit of the doubt in my
own favor it got mixed reviews it was
reviewed by marshall goldman of harvard
russian research center
this past sunday on the front page of
the book review for the los angeles
times
so the good news for me was that it was
reviewed by a pretty big gun
in this country on soviet economics
the bad news was he suggested that i was
and these words are stinging that's why
i remember them unduly and alarmist
about soviet
financial initiatives in western markets
and
their escalated borrowing activities
the reason he said so was because
he felt that the soviets in the past
when they borrowed they tend to retract
and that their their borrowing now might
be followed by a period of of reducing
their debt to the west and he said
that's based on their traditional
behavior
i think there's there's some validity in
that although they've never borrowed
nearly to the extent that they have now
under gorbachev
it's a brand new game what they're doing
not just the total amounts but the
options who's loaning money to
western europe
west germany
britain france italy japan who's the
biggest
west germany
did this this review go on to uh give
you
any credit for anything or was it all
negative yeah no actually the nice part
was he said
um see in my book which i finished as i
say um
almost a year ago
i made the declaration that the soviets
were not running a budget surplus they
were running a massive budget deficit
and and um
i think people thought how do you know
that well
this past october i mean my rationale
for it and my explanation is is in the
book based on the numbers what has to be
the case walking through their financial
statements on a step-by-step basis
in october the soviet finance minister
boris gastev
announced before a very shocked supreme
soviet that contrary to what we've been
telling you for years we are running a
budget deficit and at that point he said
it was 36 billion rubles which is about
58 billion dollars which would be
3.6 percent of soviet gnp
three months later which means this past
january
uh one of gorbachev's closest economic
advisors leonida balkin
he said
not only are we running a deficit it's
three times the amount that gus jeff
admitted it's over 100 billion rubles so
now we're talking about 10 or 11 percent
of soviet gmp i think it's even higher
than that probably closer to 15 percent
of soviet gnp
but
to answer your question and
marshall goldman said that
my work which is based on some earlier
work that was done uh bringing figures
up through the mid 70s by igor biermann
i followed his techniques in extending
the analysis
goldman said both biermann and i had
been vindicated
so i was i was grateful for that and i
even called igor biermann and and told
him you'll be happy to know
that you've been vindicated by marshall
goldman
to which he responded
i'm i was happier to know i was
vindicated by gorbachev because
gorbachev himself last month said
our massive budget deficit
is the
most serious dangerous part of the
legacy we inherited from our
predecessors and stands in the way of
our progress in the world have the
soviets read this book that you know of
on on your program c-span uh covered
um a seminar i addressed a couple of
weeks ago
the day after uh a representative from
the soviet embassy
called the american conservative union
who had sponsored that program
and asked for a copy of the book
and they said
come in and we'll sell you one
because they had bought a few
and we joked about hard currency only no
rubles
and i they just informed me this fellow
with a very thick russian accent head
call
well last week
they told me that um
oh i think his response was i will have
to get approval
to buy the book in cash
um
he came in the following week they told
me
with a 100 bill
and said i would like to um
to
buy
judy shelton's book they couldn't make
change
they didn't have the money so um they
said take the book and and when you
change change it bring it back and and
give us some money
he said no no i won't do that i will
change it and then i'll come back pay
you cash and he left well one of the
gentlemen at the american conservative
union noticed that part of the man's
heel must have fallen off and was
sitting on the floor
and so he picked it up and saved it on
the desk and sure enough about two hours
later
this soviet gentleman from the embassy
came back
he handed them the money in cash he
changed it
and uh they gave him the book and
pointed out that he'd lost part of a
shoe
and he took it and thanked him and was
walking out the door and he turned
around and said
i guess my plan
to leave a microphone in your offices
didn't work out
and they were laughing and i think that
the ideas there
there are
images on both sides i mean i don't know
that there the soviets are watching get
smart re-ones but they understood the
joke that there's essentially distrust
i'm sure the soviets react to this book
as a
cold war mentality
i think they said something to the these
people when they bought the book there
uh why why do you want to put more
missiles in the world uh why don't you
want to have international cooperation
and i think that's the soviet approach
to a book like mine that says
it doesn't make sense for the west to
loan you money
that says your your budget is in
catastrophic condition
because you've devoted so much of it to
the military
and
i think the last refuge of a scoundrel
is to to say is to respond to that
criticism by saying well you just don't
want peace by the way our producer this
program greg barker
has a copy here of the la times review
by marshall
goldman which was in the
sunday i don't know the date on there uh
february
12th
all right i just can take a look at it
um off the subject just a little bit the
hoover institution
at stanford what is it
it's a um
gathering of scholars a think tank is
what it's normally called
there are a number of nobel laureates
there including milton friedman edward
teller
it's um it's a place where
you can do research
on domestic policy issues on foreign
policy issues
with absolutely no dictated agenda
no one ever told me
what the parameters of my study would be
i proposed what i wanted to look at
which
when i originally was given a a grant a
postdoctoral grant from hoover
it was to analyze the impact of western
capital on the soviet economy
that's what i wanted to do for all i
know my conclusions might have turned
out that
it's a very
healthy
impact and and there should be more of
it the point is
hoover didn't ask me in any way to
define my um
potential conclusions it was uh it's
really an organization dedicated to
research with policy implications that
might affect the welfare of the public
hoover as at stanford in palo alto
california but you live in middlebury
virginia 54 miles from i think this
studio why how do you get how do you get
to do that well i was a research fellow
at or a research assistant to martin
anderson for about
18 months
and then i submitted with his blessing
this proposal to specifically focus on
soviet debt
and at that point
i received a two-year
fellowship from hoover
through the national fellows program
and the particular type of fellowship i
i received
the tradition was that people spent part
of the time at hoover and then they went
to washington where they were free to
affiliate with
american enterprise institute if if they
needed that or to just pursue research
the idea being that
public policy issues are often decided
in washington and some of the best
statistics resources and people involved
on a particular topic the institutions
in my case
the world bank and the imf
senate banking committee and house
foreign affairs committee the action was
in washington
so i came here to do that part of my
fellowship
and when my fellowship ended
i was well into into the book
i was still doing research in that area
still needing access to statistics to
update it
and policy things were breaking
everywhere because of the actions
gorbachev was taking
so i wanted to continue my affiliation
with hoover and they
made me a research fellow which now puts
me as
a member of the scholarly staff i have
access to the archives at hoover which
is
tremendous in the area of soviet studies
east european studies
i'm in contact with hoover scholars
two to three times a week
and i go back and forth for seminars
um at hoover when it involves this
subject live with your husband in
middlebury virginia any children no
that we have about 10 minutes this we
have to wrap it up and we've got a lot
to talk about yet i assume somebody that
if they want more than i've gotten by
this book which at
2250 probably wouldn't uh be unpleasant
to you um
there's a chapter called proper
perspective once again the title of the
book the coming soviet christ
gorbachev's desperate pursuit of credit
in western financial markets
because we only have 10 minutes i'm
gonna have to go through these quickly
but you have a number of points in this
last chapter that i want you to briefly
explain number one don't lose track of
moscow's fundamental problem
there i think we need to focus on this
massive budget deficit which means they
don't have the internal resources to
fund the military
investment and consumer spending as much
as they want so we have to interpret
all political initiatives by gorbachev
in terms of what must be his fundamental
problem one to which he's admitted
two don't underestimate the importance
of trading with the west for the soviet
union
there's a tendency for businessmen in
the west to downplay
the importance of trade with the soviets
because then they can say it doesn't
matter we can't affect the soviet
economy so why don't we just go ahead
and do business
and the point i want to make is it
matters a great deal soviet government
is effectively the agent
they can bring in goods from the west
and sell them for a tremendous profit it
helps plug up a hole
in their financial condition
it's also the only way out
of their economic conundrum right now
they need goods imported from the west
to get workers to be motivated to work
more productively they need the
technology from the west to
improve the productivity of their
equipment
it's just vital for them to have this
trade with the west it's not something
to be dismissed three don't be
excessively flattered by soviet moves
toward capitalism
yeah this is
this is a psychological problem
we start telling ourselves that the
soviets have finally seen the light and
they're moving to our way of thinking
we have to remind ourselves that what
gorbachev is doing is not capitalism
he's just taking a few expedient
elements of capitalism again the
harshest elements bankruptcy and
unemployment and failure
and using that because he's in an
emergency situation at home
four don't promote a personality cult
for gorbachev
this i think
everyone's aware of it's it's easy to do
we focus on this
personality and we have this tendency to
want to
deal with the man when we should be
dealing with the system
we have to tell ourselves that
gorbachev he could be replaced tomorrow
by
the soviet minister of defense or the
head of the kgb
and we don't want to suddenly have our
whole policy toward the soviet union
disrupted because they've changed people
at the top
um i think it's a big mistake to focus
on
personalities and could just have
terrible
implications for our overall strategy
toward the soviets five don't trade
economic and financial assistance for
soviet political concessions
this is a very tough one
because
in the united states especially
it bothers us when people aren't allowed
to immigrate
it bothers us when dissidents are thrown
into prison and we have this desire to
do whatever we can
to um to help them
and so as embodied in for example the
jacksonvanic amendment
there is this
quid pro quo that if the soviets start
complying with what we consider
standards of basic human decency
we will give them most favored nation
trade status
and allow them eligibility for
government-backed trade credits
that i think is a
not just an inappropriate trade-off but
a crass
situation to be talking about human
rights life and death on one hand and
financial favors on the other so i i
would move away from that linkage
six don't get confused over labels it's
all a transfer of capital
well this just focuses on the monitoring
problem um capital is now flowing to the
soviet union through joint ventures
because equity capital is not so much
different from debt and yet it doesn't
get picked up in the debt statistics
it's still a transfer of western
financial resources
there are the euro bond offerings that
the soviets now started and
those aren't picked up by the bis
figures or the oecd
so i think we need a new online
monitoring system just to keep track of
our total exposure to the soviet union
financially
seven improved monitoring capabilities
same idea
eight the united states must lead
again
this is the tough
part of the policy issue
i'm convinced that right now our
our allies are working on james baker
to get him to go along with this let's
help gorbachev approach
i think the united states is going to
have to
make its position clear to our allies
that
if our goal is to get the soviets to
transfer resources
out of the military
and into the consumption sector
the last thing we want to do
is to relieve that pressure that
internal economic pressure to make that
change
by providing the consumer goods from the
outside with our own money
in that sense we're giving a reprieve to
the kremlin
and we're just stopping this transition
process that i think would any soviet
leader not just gorbachev would be
compelled to respond to
and so we don't want to we don't want to
reduce that pressure we want them to
have to make that
decision of
butter versus guns on their own
are you at all surprised by any other
aspect of writing a book any reaction
you got was it difficult do you hope to
do it again
the book was a terrific
exercise you can't say things loosely
you verify all of your facts and figures
you think through your conclusions
and you decide what you're willing to go
to bat for
the book is getting more attention
than i would have ever hoped for but
it's it's very gratifying that it is i
think this is a
profound issue for uh every every
american taxpayer
he's the guy paying the bill for defense
he he has to be concerned about policy
that might end up with his dollars
effectively subsidizing loans to the
soviet union when did you know and what
aspect of this book first got people's
attention when did you know that that
this was going to get reviewed and it
was going to make a difference
you know the um
the soviets have have done the best pr
for me
because of
as the book was going to press and then
the copies were in galley form
that's when they first made the
announcement
that a budget deficit existed for 40
years they've been saying it's a surplus
so there i am going on record in prince
saying it can't be it's got to be a
terrific deficit and here's why
well to have
my assertions confirmed to the supreme
soviet by the the finance minister was a
boon and i think people thought maybe
there's other things in there that are
worth looking at did they do it because
of you
um
i'm sure it would be delusions of
grandeur for me to think so um
but
a review copy was made available in
early december to task they demanded it
in a typewritten request to my publisher
to see a copy of the book
and i think he tried to hedge a bit
and they demanded again more strongly a
week later
i i don't think it's just me there are a
lot of other people now who are saying
that the soviets are running a deficit
and it may be the pressure was such they
felt they should come clean even if at
first they just admitted a little and a
little and now they're saying no three
times as much as we said at first
i think they're responding to pressure
from me and others
in the western community of
sovietologists especially people who
look at the financial points responding
to that
this is what the book looks like the
title of it is the coming soviet crash
and our guest for the last hour
has been dr judy shelton who is a
native of los angeles currently lives in
middleburg virginia
has a phd in finance from the university
of utah a master's from the same school
and a bachelor in business
administration from portland state
university also has studied at ucla and
is currently a research fellow at the
hoover institution at stanford
university thank you for your time my
pleasure thank you for having me
[Music]
you've been watching an interview with
author judy shelton
for more information you may write to
her publisher the free press at 866
third avenue new york new york
one zero zero two two
and in a moment on c-span a look ahead
to the upcoming week in congress
[Music]
[Laughter]